oui
[Musique]
un coup de moins qu'en qui est un fils
de gêne à dire aujourd'hui est une
histoire puis quand il pas de moustiques
voilà berry mythe
preuve en est à nous c'est moi qui les
installent et les pontois et pour moi là
que c'est est rien c'est comme chez ma
cousine et la campagne et pour fêter
l'inauguration wario ware ben moi tu es
toi wathier mois 3 bis qui je me sens si
bien ici de tout et nous sommes
tranquilles à jouvray si vous deux enfin
ne restez pas là
pourquoi nous vendons âprement à xativa
chat dépens du grand yaka
ils viendront promeneurs insectes rien
car je le déteste ceux des prix du calme
du calme en vente au café des mr donnera
tout à l'heure le grand gala ne restera
pas longtemps ici je vais m'en
débarrasser rapidement
bérénice en va même moi je reste ici et
je garde mon banc il est à moi là je
cherche des parts chez ti pour un titus
c'est mon banc à éviter gyr est là
watch me fait du bien de respirer le bon
air - tôt si tu puisses tu respires
monnaire pure play rebond respire mieux
quand vous n'êtes pas vous parler c'est
très gentil de me laisser tout l'air
pour moi et les plats
je respire mieux qu'elle je suis celle
ci aussi c'est celui-ci bien ici et là
j'aime beaucoup m petite audition j'aime
beaucoup mes fleurs
moi aussi je me trouve très bien sûr ce
petit ben moi moi en pis et et titus il
est tombé à téléviseurs et les rigolos
il est tombé il était muet moi je suis
assis tous levés mais bon moi je te
voilà alors nous pouvons retourner notre
pain non là pourquoi le grand gala est
assis dessus comme un gros bonhomme qui
l'a laissé faire il m'a bouffé pour se
pousser rock
il va nous allons voir je vais le
dégonfler ce grand yaka remise où vas tu
roules attitude me fait bien rire il est
tombé plus fous je ne peux pousser toute
la place pour moi je suis le plus
grossier je suis le plus pro la ré so
migrants à s'appliquer s'applique aux
paris dit il mais malgré ça vu que là
aussi ça pète de partout tu as bien
moustiques semaine affirme dieu ils vont
me vient une musique une musique
[Musique]
j'ai chassé le grand yaka le mountain
mois nous a pas fait tout seul le grand
de là bas nous allier avec moi mallié de
temps à bord
mon cher moustiques et après après une
autre toile
[Musique]